vamos a crear una barra estabilizadora
con este sujetador de papel o clip y la
vamos a usar de manera que evite que el
robot se balancee adelante y atrás lo
que nos ayudará a ahorrar energía ya que
el robot se mueva más suavemente la
mayoría del peso es llevado por las
ruedas pero a veces cuando el robot se
mueve adelante o hacia atrás se va a
inclinar a un lado y esta barra nos va a
ayudar a que no se incline demasiado
además de que ayuda a extender la vida
de nuestra batería ya que el robot se
mueva más suavemente ahorita estamos
formando un ace enorme y vamos a tomar
esta forma de cee y doblamos los
extremos hacia abajo lo que nos dará más
espacio para pegar la barra en el robot
vamos a usar cinta aislante para pegar
la barra y para que funcione bien
tenemos que hacerle dos bultos o topes
al frente para que pueda mantener
derecho a nuestro robot lo cual nos va a
llevar algo de tiempo a ajustar ya que
si la barra sobresale demasiado no
permitirá que se mueva el robot pero
si casi no sobresale pues entonces no
evitará que el robot se bambolee así que
tenemos que encontrar el balance
correcto a prueba y error una vez que lo
logramos vamos a pegar la barra al robot
con la cinta aislante y así evitaremos
que el robot se bambolee demasiado